[Music]
good evening from buckingham palace i'm
trevor phillips and welcome to a sky
news royal special on the death of the
queen
coming up in the next hour
[Music]
farewell to balmoral the queen's coffin
leaves her scottish retreat
as preparations begin for her funeral
[Applause]
the people by their thousands pay their
respects
and celebrate the monarch's life of
service
the queen at rest in her edinburgh
palace before her coffin is placed on
public display
[Music]
king charles will travel tomorrow
to stand vigil with his mother after
first meetings with the representatives
of the commonwealth and the realms
no break with the monarchy anytime soon
australia's prime minister tells us as
the country honours the queen
it will need to continue to move with
the times
but the bigger questions about our
constitution are not ones for
this current period
and flying the flag for the late queen
and the new king as the crowds continue
to gather at buckingham palace
good evening from buckingham palace and
welcome to this special program on the
death of the queen
today the decades of planning for this
moment took hold
what the king has called his mother's
last great journey began in scotland the
country she adored a poignant progress
managed with military precision as a
late queen's cortege travelled from
balmoral to be received by three of her
children at hollywood house edinburgh's
royal residence
here in the mall public emotion the
crowds keep coming the carpet of floral
tributes spreading outside the gates
behind me
and inside the palace in spite of the
king's evident emotions
it's been down to business a reception
for diplomats from the other countries
where he is now king and behind the
scenes planning for the next nine days
and beyond
our first report tonight comes from
james matthews on the queen's farewell
to balmoral
through the gates of balmoral it was the
quietest farewell
rural aberdeenshire its birth song and
the rumble of the river deed leave the
soundtrack for a sight most sadly
the hairs carried the queen's coffin
wrapped in the royal standard of
scotland
the wreath on top was made from her
favorite flowers picked from the
balmoral guard
in the car behind the queen was escorted
by her daughter the princess royal and
her husband sir tim lawrence
the geography of circumstance had placed
the queen in balmoral when she passed
a journey's end there will be a state
funeral and set peace ceremony
but between here and there this was an
informal farewell
an opportunity for the public to say
their goodbyes
in balater near balmoral
they lined the street here they knew her
as the queen next door their village was
her village
it's just so fond of this area
it's just a very sad day for us all
very emotional today and very proud
to be part of the united kingdom so yeah
it was so dignified more than i thought
it would have been
in the hush
as
as she came through uh
and then you could hear the sobbing it's
not other stuff myself
i just found it really emotional
it's like it's almost like saying
goodbye to a family member it's just
really really upsetting
tractors were positioned by the side of
the road an agricultural guard of honour
as the cortege wound a route through
rural scotland
horse riders too
formed up in a field by the roadside as
it made its slow six-hour journey south
this journey had been meticulously
planned
even if there was no public rehearsal
here in banquet there was applause
[Applause]
elsewhere there was silence
everywhere there was respect and
remembrance
it was it was quite overwhelming to be
honest i'm very very proud to be here
i've never come along to anything like
this before but just really felt that i
wanted it was it was important
it was beautiful
once in a lifetime it's not gonna happen
again
people lined dual carriageways linking
aberdeen dundee and edinburgh beyond and
they looked on from walkways overhead
closer to edinburgh the cortege crossed
the fourth of fourth via the queensferry
crossing a bridge officially opened by
the queen in 2017.
once in edinburgh the queen's coffin was
driven through the streets towards
hollywood in the city's old town
[Applause]
the royal regiment of scotland formed a
guard of honour at the palace of
holyrood house and the queen's coffin
was received with a royal salute
it's being placed in the throne room
overnight to allow palace staff to pay
their respect
as the queen was carried inside a
daughter curtside to her mother her duty
done
this was day one of the queen's long
goodbye
which will span a nation that grew with
her and having learned of her loss
is learning to live with it
james matthews sky news in ballet
the queen's coffin started its journey
from balmoral shortly after 10 am
the cortege made its way to aberdeen
passing through baloter arboyne
bankery and pitakuta
and crossing the king george vi
bridge
it then traveled through the angus
countryside past briekin
and then on the kingsway around dundee
finally it crossed the bridge she
herself had opened across the firth of
fourth
and entered edinburgh
driving down the royal mile to the
palace of hollyrood house
and from there we're joined by our royal
correspondent rhiannon mills good
evening rhiannon you've been
following this moment for a moment
throughout this long day what are your
reflections tonight
trevor i think this was always going to
be a day where we all got to
stop and pause and really take in what's
happened over the last few days i think
when anyone loses a loved one or someone
they care about and fond about the
moment that
you see the coffin is often the time
that that finally starts to sink in
and this was the first moment that all
of us as members of the public
were able to see
the queen to see her coffin
in the hearse being driven away from her
beloved balmoral castle
and for me it was really a journey a
very long journey 175 miles that in so
many ways encapsulated
two very important aspects of the
queen's life starting at balmoral
a private place somewhere that she
enjoyed so much time with her her family
her friends her relatives she enjoyed
her passions for horses the countryside
spending time
around her dogs
and also a place where in the last 48
hours or so her family have been allowed
to
privately mourn
and reflect
but then as she traveled away from the
highlands through the likes of dundee
and we saw the crowd starting to come
out we saw the likes of tractors being
lined up along the roadside people
walking into the central reservation to
see the hearse go past it really was a
sense that a woman who had lived her
life in the public eye who had spent
days and days of her royal life
getting out meeting people across the
united kingdom around the world it was
time for her to again
venture out in public of course in the
car behind was her daughter princess
anne with her husband tim lawrence i
think again family showing that
still supporting the queen
is vital during these difficult days
and then we saw the hearse arrive at the
palace of hollyrood house where in
essence the official work was always
carried out where only in
june we saw the queen probably one of
her busiest weeks where she had the
ceremony of the keys where she also
attended other events beaming from it
we're clearly enjoying being in scotland
and today a much more somber moment as
we saw her children
greet the hearse
welcome
princess anne no doubt support her as
tonight they are
inside the palace again as a family
united in that grief
you mentioned two things uh there ian
which i i i thought were particularly
affecting one was the
obviously um not uh officially organized
line of tractors and uh the line of
riders on the route and the other was
when as you said she arrived at uh
hollywood house and her three
children were there there was a a
curious and i thought rather touching
moment where her daughter uh bowed her
head in a rather formal gesture
but also i thought in some way a rather
kind of
affectionate gesture what what will
happen
tonight as you say the family is there
with her but what happens tonight and
tomorrow
it's interesting that she'd mention that
curtsy and i think for the family
it reflects what we what we've already
seen and what we'll continue to see as
we
run up to the state funeral where you
have a family who in their tributes will
talk about
granny and mama
and talk about the queen in the warmest
of terms
and yet
the official the traditional the customs
are still carried out to show their
respects
this evening the queen's coffin is
inside
hollywood house in the throne room
and again it's a moment where royal
household staff are
allowed to privately pay their own
respect so they'll be allowed to go into
to the throne room and and take time to
pause you have to remember that for many
of those members of staff
they knew the queen well some of them
had served her for decades and speaking
to anyone who'd worked closely with the
queen certainly in the last year or so
you hear how much they they appreciated
her kindness and her warmth and yet now
it's her her royal household staff those
who knew her so well who are now having
to put the plans in place
and enact those plans when it comes to
these big ceremonial events you can't
imagine how difficult it must be for
them and we know of course tomorrow
there's another big ceremonial day
coming and they prepare to welcome the
new king king charles iii
ria and then thank you um we'll speak
again later i think um now as people
line the street to pay their respects to
the queens
thousands of people have also gathered
across the four nations of the united
kingdom to witness proclamations of king
charles iii as the new monarch
today ceremonies were held at cardiff
castle hillsborough in northern ireland
and at windsor castle and edinburgh
castle
[Music]
do now hereby with one voice and consent
of tongue and heart
publish
and proclaim
that the prince
charles
philip arthur george
is now
by the death of our late sovereign happy
of memory
become our only lawful
and rightful liege lord
charles iii
[Music]
three cheers for his majesty the king
hey back
[Applause]
saint james a degraded already
i'm louise and hartfluid do reveal a
dewey
to whom we do acknowledge
all faith and obedience with humble
affection
beseeching god
by whom kings and queens do reign to
bless his majesty
with long
and happy years
to reign over us
[Music]
uh
[Music]
wow
[Music]
do now hereby
with one voice and consent of tongue and
heart
publish and proclaim
that the prince charles
arthur george is now
by the death of our late sovereign
of happy memory
become
our only lawful
and rightful
liege lord
charles iii
god save the kingdom
[Music]
in the afternoon the king held meetings
with the secretary general of the
commonwealth and attended alongside the
queen consort a reception of high
commissioners here at buckingham palace
a clear indication of the importance
he's placing on his new role as head of
the commonwealth
let's talk more now about the new king
and the rest of today's events with the
historian and author anne
seber
good evening and thank you so much for
joining us um
i thought today the king looked pretty
much like he's getting down to business
don't you think
he clearly is he has after all had 73
years to prepare for this so perhaps we
shouldn't be surprised i've noticed a
few things where i feel he's
obviously um continuity is
the bedrock of what he he needs to show
and he's doing that but a few new things
his speech yesterday or or or the
previous day showed emotion so that's
very new that he's prepared to emote and
of course by getting out of the car with
the queen consort and mixing with the
crowds shaking hands without gloves not
being um put out when someone in the
crowd tries to kiss him this is quite
new and um the other thing i think is
that he's trying to have an element of
something modern by televising the
ceremony of accession now of course this
is a fine line between not spoiling the
mystique of monarchy not being too open
and yet being just open enough and and
sharing what's going on so i think those
are two important elements that i've
noticed
of course you know the queen the late
queen his mother embodied the national
story she was
living walking history
and for
king charles to
try and create his own narrative of what
it means to be british
i i think he's working pretty hard
already at that i think we can see these
these different elements
yes you're looking for pictures of uh
him talking to people and i i noticed
the attempt to kiss him which of course
is not the first time that's happened in
his life so i suspect took him back to
his teenage years but
i thought your your point about his um
if you like new openness
in some ways reflects
perhaps what his mother and his father
tried to do in opening up the monarchy
with documentaries and
and so on do you do you think that he
sees himself
not so much as a break but as a
development as a break with the past but
as developing what they try to do with
monarchy
well i think don't forget um
the late queen never gave an interview
so to that extent um it it would be
quite new but i think it's showing that
they're not frightened of the public i
think that's what's what's so important
and we've only seen a couple of days of
it but it does really seem that he is
embracing this new role and didn't shy
away from all of that so so that would
be very important the the other element
is of course
as he creates the new narrative of what
it means to be british he'll have some
very difficult issues and and the most
important
you could argue is keeping together the
union so to that extent he's been
greatly helped today by these potent
images
of the late queen's coffin draped with
the royal standard of scotland i mean
that's an extraordinary help for him
because it makes the feeling of being
part of a union this whole scottish
element to the early um
aspect of the morning week has certainly
helped him in the feeling that scotland
is is such a key part of the union
um i think the other thing is of course
his desire to be defender of faith and
we'll probably see more of that in the
days to come but as you rightly say he
spent today in meetings
the element of his speech that um was
very clear-cut was that he's not going
to be an interfering prince he's going
to give up all the aspects he
understands that as king he can't
continue with many of his um the the
issues and the charities that he was so
involved in and i think it remains to be
seen how that pans out
i would say he's done such fantastic
work with the prince's trust and and
it's an undersung achievement that he
will have to find a way somehow to
continue this enormous philanthropic
work without being seen as a a meddling
or an interfering king so i'm sure he's
given all these things a lot of thought
over the last few years it's just that
we the public don't quite know yet how
it'll pan out and
and indeed in his in his address he did
say that others will
carry out some of that work um just very
briefly and before we finish one of the
things that i i
i i was very struck by the last couple
of days um
the
uh
viewing of the flowers
the walkabouts
the fact that he did an address to the
nation within uh two days now um
in the unhappy
uh aftermath of uh death princess diana
all of that took days do you think the
royal household learnt from that
experience
of course they've learned and they go on
learning and i think if i've understood
correctly he did actually record his um
speech in advance and i'm not at all
surprised he would have been choked up
with the motion everyone who saw him
commented about the the genuine emotion
the red eyes that the tears that's not
to take away from the achievement of
absolutely striking the right balance in
that speech as i say full of emotion and
for me the wonderful literary illusion
that he ended with may flights of angels
um sing me
yeah
and
and thank you very much for joining us
this evening
thank you very much it's a privilege to
to talk about this thank you
well as the king prioritized stabilizing
the commonwealth and the realms as he
begins his reign a key focus of
attention will be australia
its prime minister said before the
queen's death that his country needs an
australian head of state
but today he told sky news that he will
not hold a referendum on becoming a
republic during his first term in office
instead anthony albanese told us it was
a moment to show
gratitude for the queen's service to
australia the commonwealth and the world
cordelia lynch reports from canberra on
australia's admiration for the monarch
the sights the sounds of a new sovereign
a ceremony for a new era in australia
under a king
the queen was adored here
in death they honor her
even those uncertain about the
institution
the prime minister a republican himself
leading the tributes
this is a land of cyclones of floods of
natural disasters
and queen elizabeth always reached out
to give that comfort uh to australians
at our time of need
and she was
such a a respected figure
regardless of where people stand on the
political spectrum that 70 years of
public service that that devotion to
duty uh is something that holds her in
in such high regard part of the success
of queen elizabeth reign here seems to
be that people perceived her as being
politically neutral do you think her son
will be able to achieve that too
i'm sure he's very conscious
of the need to be
above politics and he certainly has
always been that in terms of of
australia this
of course is is a substantial change the
the only monarch
that we have known in my lifetime and in
the lifetime of most australians uh has
been queen elizabeth it's reignited a
debate about a republic
do you think in this moment that that is
appropriate or perhaps even
opportunistic
well i i am of the personal view and
i've made it uh
clear that now is the time for us to pay
tribute
to the life of queen elizabeth ii to
give thanks uh for her service to
australia to the commonwealth and to the
world
and that is the focus that i have when
it comes to the monarchy do you think
though australians want to see
the institution
evolve
uh well of course and and it has evolved
and it will continue uh to evolve uh it
will need to uh continue to move with
the times
but the bigger questions about our
constitution are not ones for
this current period
this is a period in which
we are showing the grief that so many
australians are feeling at the moment
showing our deep respect and admiration
uh for uh the contribution of the queen
uh to australia she certainly had a
powerful connection and we've witnessed
that firsthand here in australia and
just to confirm though no no referendum
in your first term no
in recent days some politicians have
openly pushed for a second referendum
but the man running the country isn't
ready and neither are they
they just want the right words
to say goodbye cordelia lynch sky news
canberra australia
the labour leader sakir stama spoke
earlier about the queen's legacy and
antigua's plans to hold a referendum on
becoming a republic
well i think across the commonwealth
it's very important to recognize that
every country will evolve in its own way
according to their tradition and their
wishes
i think
the king will be an incredible head of
the commonwealth and has an ability to
bring people together i know that he has
a very very deep commitment to the
commonwealth so of course
different countries will evolve in
different ways but i think that
the king will strengthen that bond with
the commonwealth
well as we've mentioned king charles met
senior diplomats from the commonwealth
countries today
one of them was iftakar is honorary
consular official for tuvalu and he
joins me now
uh good evening safety car um
you've been a diplomat for
you've been a diplomat for
some time um how significant was it do
you think that the
new king
met you and uh
others uh other representatives so early
well i
you know to value
being
an island state
which is threatened by climate change
and
i mean even some scientists have
predicted that it may not be in
existence after a few decades
and
especially our present king king charles
iii
has been taking
very keen interest in the developments
and the effects of climate change
particularly on small islands like
tuvalu
so
the
meeting today i had the audience today i
had
with
his majesty
was actually
very interesting but obviously
the very
first thought on my mind
and which of course was a reflection of
the minds of the dwelling people
was the grief
which we have all
felt and which is in our minds in
relation to the demise of our beloved
queen
actually the people of tiwalu
have been very faithful very loyal and
very loving to the queen
there have been attempts in the past to
change divalu into a republic
and there was a referendum last year
which people rejected
and they prefer to continue
under the sovereignty of their beloved
queen and this has happened in the past
as well there was a prime minister of
tualu who actually changed the flag of
tiwalu
and he wanted to remove the union jack
from the tuvalu
flag
but he did not succeed and eventually
the
country the people of the country have
stayed on very loyal and firm
to
the
connection to the attachment they always
had with the queen as you would know
it is it is in 1974 during the reign of
the queen
that tuwaru
attained and achieved its independence
so that relationship continues to this
day
and whenever i have met the queen
i i just sorry
yeah i just wanted to mention that
whenever i have met the queen and i have
met the queen a few times
he always talked about her experience of
her visit to tuvalu in
1982.
she visited tualu with
prince philip
and
they were carried from the ship to the
shore
in a canoe on the shoulders of the
elders of the community
and that experience
she did not forget
and prince philip did not forget that
every time i met they wanted to talk
about it
and such experiences
have made a great impact
on
those people who
are far far away
in a remote and isolated
island with all these problems related
to climate change and of course
yeah
forgive me commissioner i i told you but
just one um question
you've explained i think very eloquently
the
uh affection with uh in which the queen
the late queen was held by the tuvaluan
people do you think that will extend
itself to the new king i think they're
quite they're familiar with him uh
already aren't they i'm not sure he's
visited tuvalu but uh they will know him
well you see
there are two factors here one is the
sentimental attachment
that goes back to the history of that
relationship
and it
continues with the new king
and of course the queen
had been a stalwart
monument and a pillar for tuvalu and
they very much relied on her support and
on her love
and
i'm sure this will continue in the
present era of the monarchy as well
and
our new king charles the three
will is is particularly very keen to
help the small island states and
particularly the countries which have
problems with the environment
sustainability
and
actually what is really needed in order
to
strengthen and continue this
relationship
is some concrete
uh
uh gestures of support
and uh
and how what would that be serve to car
well
what would such a gesture be
well that will particularly be
trying to
materialize
and implement
the proposals and the resolutions of
conferences like cop 26.
as you know i mean in the previous cops
as well
lots of promises have been made to help
countries like diwali to defend their
shores from the onslaught of waves and
water
and this problems still continues to
exist
and tualu particularly
has received
very very little help to defend itself
from these things and therefore i think
uh since
our
present king has been very keen on
climate change and sustainable
environment he will surely
continue his
vision
of
doing something concrete to to help such
islands and i think this is really what
is important it is not so much rhetoric
and talk and resolutions as
the real resources
for instance at a time
it was uh suggested that tuvalu should
build defense and protective walls
around the islands
and
an estimated cost was also worked out
but no funds
came and no funds have been made
available to tualu to carry out that
project
so if the card i
i suspect your message has been heard uh
probably in buckingham palace but
perhaps even more importantly uh in
downing street thank you so much for for
joining us this evening
thank you very much thank you
let's look ahead in more detail to the
next 10 days and the schedule of events
tomorrow the house of commons and the
house of lords will come together in
westminster hall for a motion of
condolence which king charles will
attend and make a speech
after that the king and queen consort
will fly to edinburgh they'll go to the
palace of hollywood house
once there they'll join a procession
where the queen's coffin will be taken
from hollywood house to sinjar's
cathedral in the city
the procession leaves hollyrood at 2 35
p.m
and the service takes place at the
cathedral at three o'clock
the king will then return to hollyrood
for an audience with scotland's first
minister nicholas sturgeon
he'll also attend the scottish
parliament to deliver a speech
in the evening the king will
stand vigil with members of the royal
family at st giles cathedral
on tuesday the queen's coffin will be
taken to edinburgh airport and flown to
raf northolt the coffin is then going to
be transported to buckingham palace by
road to rest in the bow room
meanwhile the king will travel to
belfast and visit hillsborough castle
in belfast the king will meet the
secretary of state for northern ireland
and party leaders king charles will
receive messages of condolence and
deliver a speech
the king and queen consort will also
visit sin anne's cathedral for a service
of prayer and reflection
and after that service they'll leave
belfast and return to london
on wednesday at 2 22
precisely the king will lead the
procession carrying the queen's coffin
to the palace of westminster where the
archbishop of canterbury will conduct a
short service
the queen's lying in state begins in
westminster hall it will last
four days
on the morning of monday monday week
night the 19th of september the lying in
state ends and the queen's coffin will
be taken in procession to westminster
abbey for the state funeral service
our royal correspondent rhiannon mills
joins me once again
from edinburgh um rihanna talk us
through
the plan for tomorrow and what uh the
different parts of it signify
so again it's going to be a packed
schedule for
our new king king charles iii and and
again we'll reflect those
those two things that are happening and
have happened so far in terms of
him immediately picking up the battle
when it comes to the constitutional
duties
but also
mourning the death of his mother and it
was made very clear yesterday in a
briefing that yes while he has got those
important state duties to carry out is
now our head of state for him the real
priority is making sure that he can lead
the nation and the royal family
in this period of grief of course it
starts tomorrow though at the palace of
westminster where he will address both
sides of the house he will address the
house of commons and the house of lords
so we wait to see exactly what he says
in that speech of course in the past he
has been at times been described as a
two political prince in his message to
the nation the other day though he made
it clear that he very much respects the
constitution the institutions that we
have in this country when it comes to
political process so be fascinating to
listen to his speech but then very
quickly he makes his way
up here to edinburgh and
again we are going to see a time where
both the royal family and members of the
public are encouraged to pause and
reflect and remember the queen because
the service is going to be carried out
at st giles cathedral i think it's worth
reflecting on how important the queen's
own personal faith was to her in a
christmas message she once said i like
so many have drawn great comfort in
difficult times from christ's words and
example and just as we saw a gathering
at saint paul's cathedral the day after
she died we will see something similar
happening at st giles in the middle of
edinburgh it won't just be dignitaries
and politicians though it also represent
every aspect of scottish society i'm
told of course not everyone can get
inside that cathedral but crowds again
encouraged to line the route and
what will be most striking is the fact
that we will see
the queen's children led by the king
walking behind the hearse as it drives
here from hollywood house up to st giles
cathedral again the royal family very
much leading
the crowds when it comes to this moment
of mourning they will also stage a vigil
by the coffin later on in the evening
and what's really important i think for
members of the public and something that
is only happening because the queen died
here in scotland his enzyme jars
cathedral is going to be open for 24
hours and
all of us members of the public will be
allowed to stream past the coffin in
order to pay
personal respects of course we
anticipated that lying in state would
always happen in london but the first
moment that members of the public will
be allowed to do that will actually
happen uh here in scotland taking place
from tomorrow evening
rhiannon will um
as you say this is uh the significance
of uh her dying in scotland is quite is
is extremely important um
the royal family other than the king all
have
separate titles for example prince
william i think is now duke of rotherse
as his father was
how important is the scottishness of
tomorrow's
events going to be do you think
i think we will see this reflected in
the fact that the king has made it very
clear that he wants
every nation that makes up the united
kingdom to be able to
pay their own
personal tribute and there was a set
ceremonial plan just here for scotland
which will reflect the customs that are
unique
to this country so we will see those
importantly play out tomorrow and for
the queen scotland could not have been
more important a place where during the
summer she would come for rest
recuperation of course never away from
those official duties but at least a
time at balmoral to spend time
with her family but also
the official duties were very much front
and center here as well of course it was
only around 12 months ago that i
remember being here in edinburgh as the
queen 95 years old
opened the scottish parliament here the
parliament building just a short
distance behind me on that occasion she
was ably supported by
the then prince of wales and the duchess
of cornwall but despite the fact that we
now know she was increasingly having
mobility problems she wanted to carry
that out and i think one of our guests
today
described it perfectly that even in the
saddest of times actually what this
moment has done has brought the best out
in people so whatever political
persuasion people are whatever people
might think about the continuation of
the united kingdom
today and i think the next
run-up to the next few days as we run up
to that state funeral is a time for for
people to come together and really we
saw that in the crowds here in edinburgh
today
rhiannon thank you so much i know you'll
be back on tomorrow hope you get some
rest tonight
queen elizabeth was through much of her
reign one of the most photographed and
certainly most famous women on earth
it wasn't just the public who wanted to
see her world leaders including 14 u.s
presidents or also amongst those who
valued their time with her
our international affairs editor dominic
wagon reports on the queen's global
influence
her majesty went ashore accompanied by
the governor of fiji she reinvented
monarchy and took it to the world from
young queen to global mega star
she was incredibly popular i mean she
was like this
multi-media star the lifetime of travels
would circle the planet 40 times over as
the world changed beyond recognition
queen elizabeth remained constant
confidante and confessor to presidents
and prime ministers
what's quite extraordinary is the love
and affection they had for her and
champion of a commonwealth of nations
and it's two and a half billion people
the ability to come to your level and
tell you that you're doing a good work
meant almost everything to me
as queen of canada for nearly six
decades
my pride in this country remains
undimmed
we've become used to seeing the queen on
the world stage but it was a role she
envisaged even before being crowned i
declare before you all
with my whole life
whether it be long or short
shall be devoted to your service
and to the service of our great imperial
family to which we all belong
it was a promise she would honor from
the very beginning barely six months
after her coronation embarking on a tour
of the commonwealth
[Music]
the royal couple drew enormous crowds
welcome was the word formed by some of
the 17 000 children on melbourne cricket
ground there was no doubt they met it it
was clear that this was going to be a
very different kind of monarch
the queen when she came to the throne
she was very young but she had very
clear ideas of how she wanted to shape
her role and definitively travel and
international collaboration and building
an international community and
particularly the commonwealth was so
important to her the queen and prince
philip toured the commonwealth for six
months taking in its vast size and
diversity
by the end the young queen was already
becoming a global icon
it was now a broadway that supplied the
dictate snowstorm
the status cemented a few years later
when she took new york by storm
americans came out in their thousands
inside the great assembly hall 2 500
delegates and their wives rose to greet
the queen
when the queen went on her visits in the
early days no one had any idea she'd be
so popular they had no idea there'd be
thousands of people the advisors were
really quite surprised by the level of
popularity the level of fascination the
fact that everyone seems to be out there
on the street who wants to see a glimpse
of the queen and she was incredibly
popular i mean she was like this
multi-media star she was like the
ultimate celebrity bigger than a
hollywood celebrity
on the maintenance of understanding
between us
the future of the free world depends
she was already mastering the arts of
soft power her personal chemistry with
leader after leader would prove one of
her most effective
assets i saw her with leaders like
president yeltsin and sort of again the
level of
conversation and confidence and
ability to to observe your discretions
and and secrets
were very high and i think you know
got on well because he respected the
queen of having
some enduring qualities that are not
related to politics or the stage of
george politically
very few could claim to be on an equal
footing with the queen nelson mandela
was one i mean she could speak very
frankly with him because he was a prince
in his own tribe so in that sense he had
an easy way uh with the queen he's the
only head of state i've ever had call
the queen elizabeth
at home the queen hosted world leaders
some of them less savory than others but
treated them all with the same decorum
and royal welcome
her role was far from just ceremonial
she had a diplomatic importance with a
global reach and depth politicians could
only dream of
we in britain have often underestimated
the immense impact that the queen had on
the whole of the world
with america she had met 14
u.s presidents nobody in the world not
even in america has met 14 presidents
and then taking a place like ireland she
was pivotal in bringing about that
rapprochement
between britain and ireland in 2011. so
a hugely understated but very
significant influence globally the
monarchy continues the monarchy will
always continue that's what it's
designed to do but will anybody coming
in now
have that same
clout that same uh footprint on world
history obviously not the queen
driving the queen's ambition above all
was a passion for the commonwealth to
see something good rise out of the end
of empire
secretary general says the queen played
a unique role for all of its leaders
you could tell her anything
and she'd never talk about it
and she had the wisdom
and the generosity to listen
and then to give really sage
quiet advice and so
i think if you had the privilege as a
number of us have of seeing her
interact with them
what's quite extraordinary is the love
and affection they had for her i commend
the queen's young leaders of 2018. but
the queen's love for people extended far
beyond leaders and politicians she had a
passion for the youth of the
commonwealth
like derek omari who set up a charity
for disabled children in ghana age 19
singled out by her majesty for the
queen's youth leader awards
it was it was a day that
nobody ever thought about i knew where i
grew up never ever thought of in my life
that i even leave ghana to the uk and
then come all the way to the bakken
palace and be on it
and and one of the things that really
left
that that has gotten stuck with me
was
the chance to meet her in person
have a conversation with her
humanness and the ability to come to
your level and tell you that you're
doing a good work keep doing it keep
going on and we are proud of you
meant almost everything to me
[Applause]
for rihanna patterson recognized for
setting up a dementia charity the queen
was a personal inspiration she was a
young person taking on this leadership
role and she had to kind of
find herself in it quite quickly you
know there was a lot of formalities a
lot of rules a lot to take in and it was
something that was quite sudden um
so i think she is relatable in that
regard like taking on the stunts at a
young age
the woman who took on so much in her
twenties will go on inspiring so many
other young people like her for decades
and carry on travelling for as long as
her health would letter
the queen transformed the monarchy
turning it into a globe-shotting
multimedia phenomenon years ahead of her
time letting britain punch above its
weight in the world and leading a
commonwealth of nations
her death leaves a void as she has
mourned by hundreds of millions far
beyond these shores
dominic waghorn sky news
the queen was remembered at church
services across the country and the
commonwealth today
the archbishop of canterbury said she
had taught people as much about god as
any other contemporary figure
katarina vittotsi reports on the
congregation's remembering a devout
defender of the faith
she is the only monarch most of us have
ever known
and today at liverpool parish church the
late queen was mourned by some like a
member of family
[Music]
this was a special requiem service
a chance to remember an extraordinary
life
we give you thanks
for her love of family
and her gift of friendship
for her devotion to this nation
and the nations of the commonwealth
the queen's passing brings global
cultural change
and a new national anthem with
unfamiliar words
arthur speed who's 77 remembers the
previous king
but the late queen became his constant
she was a one-off wouldn't she what a
lovely lovely lady lovely
when i was at sea
every friday seven o'clock used to toast
the queen
but i'm gonna look forward to king
charles
hopefully he'll do as good as his
i'm sorry
church services like this one held here
today and those indeed across the
country and the commonwealth have given
people a chance to pay tribute to the
late queen but in many ways they also
reflect the way in which queen elizabeth
ii lived her own life
at her coronation 70 years ago the queen
pledged to lead the church of england
but the public pageantry was matched by
personal faith
seen in times of celebration like
christmas day trips to church
or more recently at the funeral of her
late husband
her role as defender of the faith will
be remembered
a late majesty
taught us much
if not more
about god and grace both in words
and the actions that reinforce them
than any other contemporary figure
the queen once said her faith guided her
through good times and bad it feels then
particularly poignant the places of
worship like litchfield cathedral in
staffordshire have become such focal
points during this time of national
mourning
she was just like the nation's grandma
weren't she
she just everyone just loved her there
was nothing not to love about her really
she's really important for everyone and
a lot of people looked up to him thought
she was amazing really and i did as well
it's a sense many share
a feeling
many will miss
catherine rivertotsi sky news
[Music]
it's a name which resonates with another
era treetops the remote safari lodge
hotel in kenya where princess elizabeth
found out she had become queen
today 70 years on her majesty was being
remembered there and by the community
around it
aleister bunkel reports on the treetops
tributes
[Music]
on the 5th of february 1952 princess
elizabeth attended a service at some
phillips church in the foothills of
mount kenya
she didn't know it then of course but
within hours her life would change
completely
early the following morning her father
king george died and she became the
queen
as we continue to remember
the pulpit was a gift from her and the
duke of edinburgh and her coat of arms
still hangs in the church today after
her coronation the queen sent a section
of the carpet that lay in westminster
abbey that day to this small rural
church which must have had special
memories for her
she is part of the congregation in the
records she's there and part of your
family she's sort of our family that is
part of our family and being part of our
family she is part of us and
we are also mourning the
her death and we also
part of the
part of the family that is money
she spent her final evening as a
princess at treetops lodge in the peace
and quiet of aberdeen national park
surrounded by wildlife and sleeping in a
tree house on the edge of a watering
hole
the tree house was burnt down a few
years later by the mao mao during the
uprisings against british rule where the
hotel was rebuilt
and your father cooked for her
my father cooked lunch for her and she
was telling her stories how she was
asking the question very juvia she was
making fun
oh the nicest fair food the night then
the food
the food was very nice they make jokes
hey because we have just get it from the
farm right now
that is nice i will come back again
a handwritten note lists the animals
they saw during their stay water buck
baboon elephants and bull rhinos
fighting in the morning
the princess elizabeth suite is now the
hotel's jewel in the crown
memories of her stay a part of the
history of this place
i felt i we have lost someone that
had loved kenya and
treat approach as well because this is
the home of the loyal farmer sb so many
people say this is her hotel
if you go out and ask people you said
that's queen's hotel
when princess elizabeth heard the news
of her father's death she cut the royal
visit short and rushed back to london
but she returned to treetops lodge in
1983 to see the animals and the staff
and spend time in the place where she
enjoyed the final hours before her life
changed forever alastair bungalow sky
news in kenya
[Music]
that's all for this special program
coming up next news at 10 with jillian
joseph here at buckingham palace and
anna botting in edinburgh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you